two one i'm going to play
knife any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic
there he is from the seti institute in
mountain view
how are you seth well i'm possibly okay
i think i'm all right still above ground
that's what people tell me is the
correct answer yeah i always say you
know people say oh it's my birthday i'm
like well
another year older but i guess it's
better than the alternative of not
getting older
uh your perennially jew uh you know
juvenile but in a good sense
youthful seth you never seem to age it
must be studying you know the billions
of year old
cosmos that you and i both study uh it's
always a treat to be with you
and i thank you this is alien week on
the into the impossible
podcast yesterday we had on mick west a
noted uh debunker or classifier of
uh of unidentified alien
phenomena or unidentified flying
phenomena and i
made note today on twitter that he got
his start uh he was a video game
designer
and he started off by making a tony
hawk's
a video game which uh has to do with an
identified flying object have you ever
seen tony hawk he like
hovers in space and like orbits and and
rotates around
so that's pretty cool and uh i thought
we'd talk a little bit about it because
you know in the news lately are all
these
uh phenomena have to do with with uh
with potential alien techno signatures
in the form of
of ufos and i'm hoping to have on some
of the
uh some of the pilots of various
military aircraft that have come
to uh to be uh featured in 60 minutes
another
four hour and uh and hopefully we'll get
some of your feedback on it so
have you had a chance to see any of the
the footage from from these
military uh infrared cameras or any of
the other
eyewitness accounts have you followed
any of that seth well i have looked at
the
the better known videos maybe they're
the only ones at least three different
maybe four different ones several made
with these fleur
flir which means you know forward
looking
infrared cameras uh you know rotating
tic tacs and stuff like that things
setting over or
settling into the ocean stuff like that
yeah i have seen them
still there
i i don't hear any i don't actually hear
you i think
something is sorry i muted myself for a
second
oh it was not it was not the military
not this time no could have been the
aliens though
so yeah so you haven't seen any of those
yeah there are some you know ones that
are more credible than others
i tend to think i'm a pilot you remember
you you met me at the airport once i
flew a little plane up there
and when i spoke at the seti institute
and one of the things i
you know kind of have thought about is
you know has anyone
looked at the simulation not of the of
the ufos
but of actually the pilots and what they
would have experienced from inside of a
of a high performance jet vehicle
capable of almost mach 2 speeds
they're not designed to go super slow
and they're not designed to you know
cruise very low over the ocean
but i want to point out that in your
book confessions of an alien hunter
which i am going gonna
bring up a picture of as we speak
because i have that technology
and i have it at my fingertips i'm going
to bring up the cover of it
i love this book i read it i listened to
it i read it in kindle
i think i have a signed copy by you too
all these things it's now a collector's
item one of the additions on the the
so-called collector's item edition on
amazon is like 500
as is one of mick west's books so that's
pretty cool but anyway
um you talk about what would be the
implications if true so
first thing i hear seth a lot why are
they visiting us now
and so what you've said in the book and
i want you to elaborate on it one reason
purported by uh people that are
enthusiasts
about the alien actually explanation is
that they see
our path as one of heading towards
destruction they see
the blast of nuclear detonations in the
50s 60s etc
and they see us on a path towards
destruction and they come to
save us in a certain sense how do you
respond to that
well uh you know one could argue at
length
that the aliens probably don't care what
we do to ourselves any more than i care
what the mosquitoes outside this
building are doing
maybe they're doing things that are not
in their best interest but i'm not going
to go out there and
try and save them so you could argue
that but that that's an argument about
alien sociology right and we don't know
much about that so
what i would say is this just let's just
stick with the physics
uh yeah maybe they've seen our nuclear
tests and they go back to 1945 right
i mean it turns out that it's a lot
harder to find somebody's nuclear test
than it is to find
their radars because the radars are on
24 7 the nuclear tests are over pretty
quickly
but you know leave all that out maybe
they they did see
the detonations beginning in 1945 you
know hiroshima nagasaki
nevada all the places where we set off
atomic bombs maybe they did let's assume
so that means 1945 since 1945 55 65
75 70 76 years ago
all right so it's just going out into
this information the flashes are going
out into space at the speed of light
and they hit a planet where there's some
klingons on there and they say oh my god
you know these guys have nuclear weapons
we got to do something about it sure
it's going to cost
70 trillion zillion galactic crusaders
to do it but we're going to do it
right okay so what they're going to do
is they're going to send some saucers
dirt to fly around i
as far as i can tell they haven't done
anything with regard to our nuclear
capabilities but
let's say that they just decided to do
that
well okay their spacecraft can't go
faster than the speed of light that's
the limit so let's assume they go at the
speed of light
right 76 years to
for them to get the information another
76 years
to get back here or whatever it's
that wouldn't work because we wouldn't
see them yet but what if they were half
that
far away instead of 76 years right they
were
38 light years away right so
all right the bombs go off 38 light
sorry 38 years later they see the flash
they make a quick decision we're going
to intervene and it takes them 38 years
to get here
at best right so that means they have to
be within 38 light years of
us and the total number of stars within
38 light years
is yeah well it's a few thousands a few
tens of thousands
that's a small number in astronomy and
the chances that there's some
you know civilization with these
capabilities within that distance strike
me is rather small
so i think it's remarkable that they're
here and it's the argument
is even stronger if you go back to you
know sightings seen in the late 40s or
early 50s
it becomes almost impossible for them to
be here on the basis of anything they
might know about
uh humanity or maybe they're coming here
for
exploitation of some resources that they
might need or that they might
want to uh you know extract from us and
some sort of conserved quantity that
they might lack is there any
reason to expect that aliens might have
we might have something that aliens want
perhaps a kardashian or two
yeah well well if they took them i mean
i'm not sure my life would be altered
greatly
but uh you know i've been on panels
where we've discussed what
what do we have to offer the aliens in
the movies it's often water but that's
kind of a stupid thing
for them to come here to get because
water you know what does it make weighs
65 pounds per square
or per cubic foot or whatever water is
very dense it's heavy
and it's expensive to get it and the
facts are the universe is
chock-a-block with water because water
is h2o hydrogen is three-quarters of the
universe by weight so there's plenty of
hydrogen out there
and oxygen is the third most common uh
element
in the universe so h2o is everywhere we
find it everywhere in the solar system
it's going to be everywhere in their
solar system they're not going to come
here for water
anymore then i'm going to you know walk
to bed to get lunch
i can get lunch a lot more easily than
walking to the bed
so and and these panels kind of disgus
kind of came to the conclusion that it
was actually nothing
in terms of resources that they could
find here
that they couldn't find much much nearer
by
their home planet so that doesn't make
sense they might come here to
breed with us that's a frequent theme
it's a frequent thing because you know
it's something that scares people and
that's why
it's often offered is what the aliens
are here to do but it wouldn't work you
know it wouldn't work anymore then you
could
you know kidnap a roach from your garage
and breed with it you're not going to be
able to do that it's going to be
uncomfortable so
that's that's not a reasonable uh
scenario for them coming here
there's essentially nothing we have
culture that they might be interested in
you know
they like uh what they find in the art
museums and so on they don't have
exactly that
they might take that or maybe they're
just here as explorers you know they
just want to know what's in the galaxy
that's
fair enough but then why now and finally
they might
just be coming here to proselytize they
want to convert us to the galactic
church
that's something that's certainly
incentivized a lot of our exploration
now some say that's exactly what we'd
expect you to say because the seti
institute
is not prepared even if this were to be
true
because you are used to searching for
electromagnetic signals which is kind of
uh
your your grandmother's type of
technology you're not used to searching
for techno signatures
the type that uh avi loeb past guest on
the into the impossible podcast is
spoken about
um what do you say is there a protocol
let's say this
turns out to be actually what it is
depicted by many of the
proponents of the alien visitation
hypotheses is there a protocol or are we
basically going to start
you know kind of you know building the
building the road map as
a as they introduce themselves for
dinner
yeah well i think so i think the latter
uh i have been on ask i don't know how
many times
does the pentagon have some sort of
protocol if you like that term
for dealing with you know visitors from
outer space
i don't know what's in the depths of the
pentagon i've been in the pentagon many
times actually because i lived two miles
from it and my father worked for the
navy and
as a consequence i used to go to the
pentagon to use the swimming pool i kind
of think
but that doesn't tell you what they're
doing there i don't know what they're
doing there but i doubt that there's a
protocol because in fact
it's just a very simple argument if they
can come here
it doesn't matter what your protocol is
whatever they want to do they can do it
because they have the technology
to do things that are centuries away if
not
farther for us so it's a
you know bit silly would be like the
the native americans on wattling island
in the caribbean in 1492. do they have a
protocol
in case some spanish ships come over the
horizon i i don't think they did they
didn't anticipate it but
in any case if they did have a protocol
it wouldn't have mattered i mean
you know these guys get out of the ship
and they look at them and they you know
try and talk at one another and neither
one can understand the other and so
forth
so i i doubt that there's a protocol but
it doesn't matter if there is
the only protocol that would work is
maybe to negotiate
now on the other hand some of the
research that's done at the seti
institute which i
urge folks to support as i do i'm a
long-term
donor i'm not only a client i'm also a
member
uh but the seti institute has done a
pioneering work on
what's called extremophiles and so forth
we used to think that you know
life was very chauvinistically would
have to look like us on the cover of
your book is a
three-fingered one thumbed
uh alien finger you know kind of
handprint um
we don't now think that aliens or even
life has to look very much like us talk
about the research that your colleagues
have done at the seti institute on
extremophiles that suggest that
life could survive radiation hardened
environments uh
deep sea environments acidic
environments talk about
how life finds a way as dr jeff goldblum
described in jurassic park yes well
jeff had that line written for him well
uh indeed
life is tough no spoilers
it's not not much of a spoiler uh
you know once you get life started it's
very hard to stop it i mean
you think of what's happened on the
earth of course there were the ice ages
oh yeah there was that big rock that
landed 66 million years ago in the
mexican yucatan
and you know wiped out the dinos and
essentially three-fourths of everything
else
you know that that was bad day uh we've
had snowball earth episodes at least
once where the whole planet is covered
in eyes and story none of this is
has has stopped life yeah it slows it
down you know
uh you you lose you lose those big
sauropods or their big teeth
yeah yeah but life goes on so that's a
very obvious demonstration of the fact
that once you get life started
it you know it just spreads around and
it just fills all the niches that it can
and it's very hard to get rid of so uh
you know i
i think the real question is not can
life
survive and that's the study of
extremophiles you know you find
bacteria and the fuel tanks of jetliners
and stuff like
that it isn't whether they can survive
the real question is
can you get it started in the first
place because if you don't do that it
doesn't matter whether it could have
survived the question is how do you get
life started and that's that's a
difficult subject because
the evidence is always very very tenuous
because
you know single-celled organisms don't
make great fossils so
we don't know how that happens and you
know we
we're interested for example in you know
finding life on mars and everybody knows
about the
perseverance rover rolling around the
landscapes of our little ruddy buddy out
there
trying to find evidence for life and it
might do so or it might
not do so you should ask yourself what
happens if it
doesn't find life right that there was
once bacterial life on on mars that
would be a big downer
because if we find it we can say okay
well at least it looks like getting
biology started isn't so hard
and yeah exactly i want to look at that
you know people talk about all findings
evidence of water actually just today
there was announcement of
uh two missions to go to venus and i've
had uh sarah seeger on the podcast
hoping to have jane grieves authors of
venus
phosphine discovery what have you made
about that we haven't spoken since those
discoveries were announced
uh late last year um does that er
does that obviously the nasa missions
were long in the planning they're
they're not just sort of
responding to you know late last year's
news
although that would not be a bad reason
to to develop
mission uh nasa's less kind of a
reactionary than that
but um but what do you make of the
possibility of life on venus
as an extremophile or as a a different
modality to look for
uh missions to go to mars what do you
make of these missions are they even
looking for life first of all
well i think that they are at least one
of them is because they're looking for
this phosphene this gas that was found
in the atmosphere of venus at an
altitude you know like
20 miles up or something like that where
the temperatures are
you know completely comparable to the
temperatures in austin texas
i mean they're very you know they're
okay they can survive they can support
life and the phosphine gas itself was a
clue because
phosphine is is a hard gas to make or at
least it's not made
frequently by many reactions in
volcanoes volcanoes make phosphate and
bacteria you make phosphine so
if there's phosphine there the question
is well where'd it come from
it could come from volcanoes but if you
just do the numbers it turns out you'd
need to have
venus completely pock marked with
volcanoes active volcanoes
in order to account for the phosphate
and that doesn't seem to be the case
and the other possibility is it was made
by bacteria floating in the
in the upper atmosphere of venus where
the temperatures are salubras
salubrious and so forth uh that's
extremely enticing because that shows
you an example
of where life got started where the
conditions were really hard
but it still got started somehow well
for me the problem is that the detection
of phosphine i think is
somewhat tenuous because it involved
some spectral work radio spectral work
and they
they fitted a ninth order polynomial or
something to the spectrum and i i've
done a lot of that sort of research
and you never fit a ninth order
polynomial to any uh any spectrum that
you've
obtained with a radio telescope because
you can fit anything
so anyhow as i i think the thing is
nasa decided to go vin to venus because
venus has been
kind of uh you know in the background
here for a long time it's been mars
mars mars and more mars and now there
are two things going to venus
it's a tough environment it's hot there
but dug on it i think it's going to be
interesting
yeah if it can cruise around in the
clouds of venus you know that
could could add a nice uh a nice blurb
to nasa's resume
uh so people are talking about other uh
other aspects a question that you and i
talked about earlier in the recorded
interview that we did
for later re-transmission on the same
into the impossible
network station a reminder i'm talking
to uh dr seth shostak of the seti
institute
in northern california a good friend of
the show
and a host of the big picture science
podcast and radio
show and you should all subscribe to
that as well and follow him on twitter
and other social media outlets we were
talking earlier about you know why use
electromagnetism at all
as a search for uh as a search modality
and people are asking that as well
in the uh in the in the chat as as we
speak
so you want to talk a little bit about
that we we did discuss that earlier
today
but for the benefit of the audience
members who uh aren't uh
able to travel back in time with us uh
is it possible
to you know that we're too kind of uh
recency focused you know there's this
primacy recency bias that human beings
have that the most recent thing that we
encounter we're gonna
fixate and sink all of our resources
into uh might it be that we should think
other ways of of
searching for extraterrestrial
intelligence other than the
shiny newest thing that we just invented
well
you know that's an enticing thought
right that we're too anthropocentric
we're too fixated on the technology of
the day
and the technology of the day and when i
say day i mean last maybe century or
something
is electromagnetic radiation others
radio waves
lasers anything like that and you could
say well maybe you know a hundred years
an hour a thousand years from now
we'll look back and think oh that's so
quaint they were using this
you know this silly technology of the
time to find the aliens meanwhile
they're on
uh you know some other transformational
i don't know i can't even remember uh
the the terms that are used in science
fiction for these communication modes
that go faster in the speed of light
there is no such communication mode as
far as we tacky on it
well tachyons yes a lot of people seem
to think that quantum entanglement
would allow instantaneous communication
but that's a misunderstanding of
quantum entanglement it doesn't actually
allow that but you know
this is may you go with it you go with
the science you have
so that explains why all these
experiments are always using
if you will the trendy science of the
day because
you know that's the best science they've
got and and i think that that applies
here
very good so another question uh that
i'm getting is you know if they had
advanced
uh technology that could potentially you
know
outdo our technology et cetera traveling
uh throughout the galaxy
perhaps uh that you know as they would
travel
wouldn't they encounter many many
hazards along the way you know we think
about
uh the uh star wars you know kind of the
the warp drives the test star track star
wars
uh but aren't there other hazards of
interstellar travel even if they could
master warp drive
and handle that that very very perilous
deceleration phase at the very end
are there other hazards aren't there
other hazards rather from just basic
physical principles
that they would have to face along their
journey at close to the speed of light
well if they're going you know with the
physics we know which it says
is to say they're not going quite the
speed of light let alone you know three
times the speed of light
whatever uh then they're moving through
space very fast
and you could say well so what i mean
space is empty and it is largely empty
but it's not entirely empty
uh there's there's what's called
interstellar material
in space and even in the you know the
the most unappealing the deserts if you
will
of of the milky way you still have at
least one particle per cubic centimeter
right there always particles of hydrogen
if you will particles they're just
atoms of hydrogen and normally they
wouldn't bother you they don't bother me
i don't disturb my sleep or anything
so what would these uh you know atoms of
hydrogen or actually little molecules of
two had uh atoms of piping
you know and they hit the spacecraft at
99.9 percent the speed of light or
whatever
they're going to punch through the uh
the skin of the spacecraft punch through
you and
you know disrupt the cells in your body
and you probably just kill yourself
so there are hazards of going through
space at very high speed
and the mitigation for that uh according
to
your most recent guest uh on the show or
at least at the institute
michio kaku suggests that there'd be no
reason for
physical entities for aliens to travel
at all whatsoever
in fact there'd be uh just a digital
code an avatar
that you would be beamed literally but
only in digital code a clone
seth would be traversing traipsing about
the galaxy
uh what do you make of that uh as a as a
prospect and perhaps now we're back to
electromagnetic
formula formulations of extraterrestrial
intelligence as a detectable signature
yeah well i think it makes sense in some
you know to some degree
i mean you know the number of base pairs
in your dna in other words the
information
dna would fit on a cd you don't even
need a dvd just a cd
right so that's uh sorry i use betamax
damn it
uh yeah well you're probably not
recording your entire
uh genome but you could fit that onto a
cd so it's not a lot of information
you could broadcast it into space you
know in the course of minutes
so why send the baryons when you can
why'd you send the in why don't you just
send the information if somebody across
the country has a book that uh they want
me to read they could mail the book
or they could send me a pdf file if you
will right and
by doing that it gets to me much more
quickly and at lower cost
everybody involved so uh i think what uh
professor kaku was saying is that
you know we won't build rockets to go
into space we'll just send the
information
now you could take that cd of brian
keating
right and you know your dna and just
send that to some other place and say
well now
you know brian's going into space at the
speed of light which he would be
but it does presume that at the other
end at the alien
end that they can do something with that
sequence of your dna do they know what
to do with it do they know that okay so
now i need a
uh you know a phosphorous atom here and
a
nitrogen atom there and so forth could
they reconstruct it at the other end
maybe not i mean i don't know how clever
they are but they might not be able to
do that they might not be able to figure
it out and if they
did even if they did what they would end
up with
is brian keating's genome and you know
they'd culture that on a petri disk
and then they would get brian keating as
he was when he was born with
essentially no information they would
miss the college education
that's right and that reminds me that i
i did send you a copy of my book
but it wasn't read in any form let alone
in digital form uh no i'm just kidding
you you did that you did of course
support
support me when we were last together at
the seti institute uh about two years
ago with alex philopenko
of uc berkeley astronomy question from
scott brown
itf in the flesh i don't know what that
stands for
us uh he asked does seth feel that the
idea
of an advanced race of beings or life
forms observing
and interacting with him with humans is
completely impossible
and if so why well i think it's
completely impossible but it's you know
it's not
going to be like it is on tv where they
just sort of stand in front of you and
you know talk to you in in perfect
colloquial
american english they don't even have
british accents always wondered about
that but in any case
yeah i i think we could interact at a
certain minimum level of
iq if you will i mean i can't interact
for example with the
hummingbirds in my backyard very well
and i walk out there and they know i'm
there
they've seen me they sense my presence
and i sense theirs because they
immediately begin to
defending their territory which usually
includes my entire backyard
you know they didn't pay that mortgage
but in any case there's some level of
interaction always possible
but in terms of communication that takes
a little bit longer
i think if they had any interest in that
they would you know give us a
picture dictionary or something like
that and maybe we could
find some com common you know
denominator if you will in language
but language is already something that's
slightly anthropocentric
so i don't know but i i cannot imagine
that we'd find some other creatures and
couldn't uh
communicate with them in some ways i
mean you know we understand a little bit
about dolphins
when they come up and ask for another
fish so i think at some level
you might be able to to communicate
what do you make of uh professor adam
frank's suggestion that
uh one way to look for uh this uh
civilization of uh you know is by
looking for a techno signature in the
form of
uh atmospheric chemistry changes via
terraforming global warming atmospheric
chemistry
methane signatures etc what do you make
of that hypothesis
well i mean that's certainly interesting
i actually have a paper
it's an astrobiology magazine i think in
january anyhow
i say that actually maybe a better way
to do study is to indeed look for
artifacts
because then the aliens don't have to be
alive now it's like i think i'm making
analogies like finding the pharaohs of
egypt
very hard to do i mean they are there
they've just been moved to a new museum
but they're just lying in a box
not making much noise so it's it's maybe
less than satisfying
but at least you could find the pharaohs
in in a sense but a better way would
just be to go to the outskirts
on the west side of cairo and you would
find these big pointy buildings
and you say well you know the pharaohs
have built this thousands of years ago
and
so this is good evidence i mean i i
think
you could do that but the idea that you
could find for example
uh hydrofluorocarbons in our
atmosphere because of hairspray or
whatever and it's something that doesn't
belong in our atmosphere and they would
do spectral analysis
and and find that stuff i i think that's
maybe a little too simple because
actually how long were the fluorocarbon
carbons in our atmosphere you know it
was recognized as a problem was
destroying the ozone
and they were you know that that problem
was solved within a few decades
at most so most of the things that are
in our atmosphere that would indicate
that we are here
things that we're responsible for in the
atmosphere are very short-lived
right even global warming all that co2
right the
the hope is that we will solve that
problem within you know
50 years 100 years 500 years whatever
and so
the fraction of time that a planet would
have these kinds of
signatures in its atmosphere strikes me
as fairly fairly low
so uh cryptalicious which was the name i
was going to choose from my second born
child
is asking a seth you have unlimited font
let's not make it
unlimited because i think that's a
little bit of a stretch but let's say
you have uh
2x the allen telescope array funds uh
you have
one new project that you can spend it on
only one you can't
develop an endowment for the the seth
showstack uh library wing and uh
endowed uh endowed uh hovercraft
you have one project what do you spend
it on well
if it's just twice what was spent to
build the island telescope rate
then i would use that money to build the
allen telescope array i would i would
finish it the original design
had 350 antennas in fact we have 42
and with 350 antennas it's actually a
qualitative change in what it could do
so if you're talking about that order of
magnitude that's you know under 100
million dollars so
with that order magnitude that's what i
would do if you really had unlimited
funds if that's really the question
uh you know you'd put uh you'd put some
sensitive radio telescopes on the
back side of the moon the side we don't
see from earth
because that would be shielded from all
the interference here
on our home planet and uh you know be
radio quiet and you'd have a much better
chance of finding something my first
guest on the into the impossible podcast
uh was my late great friend freeman
dyson
and uh starduster is asking how would
you go about searching for a dyson
sphere i think that's a cool question
yeah well a warm question actually uh
it's uh
it's it's actually been done many times
people have tried this and they've
people have looked for if you will uh
dyson spheres in the galaxy in other
words
for those who don't know what a dyson
sphere is it's just you say if you
really want to solve the energy problem
what you do is you
take a part of a planet that's not so
useful to you like neptune
and you just rebuild it as a shell
around the earth
way beyond the orbit of the earth so you
don't interfere with the earth
and you just align it with uh solar
cells
that you know turn the sun's energy into
well electrical energy
and you just you know radio that back to
earth so now you have all the energy you
can possibly use
much more than you can possibly use and
uh you know there are no emissions and
no waste products
no pile of ash at the other side of the
boiler
i mean yeah and so dyson said that this
is what advanced societies would do and
these things are in principle detectable
because
the outside of these things always emits
some infrared and people have looked for
infrared in uh you know in surveys of
the milky way
and they find a few things the trouble
is that infrared is produced in many
star systems because of dust so it's
hard it's hard yeah
absolutely yeah so uh let's see we have
more questions coming
in from uh do you believe that
uh intelligence is an evolutionary
advantage or a disadvantage
and do we expect it to be rare or common
outside of earth
i guess that's predicated on a prior
whether or not you think life is common
outside of the earth or not well i mean
i
i think that it is a somewhat different
question than saying you know is a
biology going to be common i mean we
could answer that if we found any
evidence for a previous biology on on
mars but it it's rather doubtful that
there was ever intelligence on my heart
although maybe elon musk will change
that soon uh
yeah i mean that's a very legitimate
question actually and it's one that
for which the answer is not very clear
you could say that nature's not
interested in
intelligence right we've had life on
this planet for four billion years
roughly
and for almost all of that none of the
life was very clever
right never building anything no
technology no smelting of metals
any of that right so nature's not
interested in
intelligence and and that's a thesis you
can prove to yourself by walking around
your neighborhood
nature's not interested in intelligence
but it is interested
in survival so if intelligence increases
your chances of survival then you know
nature will go along
and that's what's happened i mean
obviously humans have come to
dominate the planet and uh you know
our simian friends and ancestors they're
pretty clever compared to
most life on earth uh and their other i
mean crows are pretty clever and
dolphins are pretty clever and so forth
so it looks like
nature does keep trying or it doesn't
try but it allows
the evolution of intelligence in species
and if it turns out to pay off then
it keeps making that so i think that
intelligence might be very very common
but there's no proof of that
i mean you have to ask yourself if the
dinos hadn't been wiped out 66
million years ago there would still be
dinosaurs here and they they weren't
really all that smart
yeah absolutely so let's see we've got
um
right uh looking out uh further
so i don't think you commented very much
on uh omuamua
uh lately is that something we can
discuss there's some interest in that
from some of my listeners
is a muammua credible is it more likely
that it comes from a techno as a techno
signature of a naturally
occurring phenomenon within our solar
system or
an exosolar system as a icy body or
something like that and then i'll have a
follow-up about icy bodies later
okay actually i'm supposed to be in
another meeting at this point
so i may have to talk about but let me
just
say this you know i'll be lobe at
harvard after all this
he's a very smart guy has said that a
muammu
might be a solar sail or some remnant
from somebody else's solar system
it's clear that it comes from somebody
else's solar system what's not clear is
that
it's some sort of manufactured item and
we'll never know because a muammar was
seen
when it was already on its way out of
the solar system and uh
you know it was only seen as a dot one
pixel in the campus
pretty hard to say what it was and
actually the colors of this thing
and you could measure the colors we're
very consistent with it being an
asteroid
so i think most people in the uh
research community think that's what it
was
but you have to say gee that's pretty
lucky you know somebody throws a rock
into space and it comes right into our
solar system
as closely as it did it just you know
wheeled around the sun and
headed on out and the chances of that
happening are very small unless there
are a lot of these rocks
and i think the answer to a mill will
become clear if we in fact
find more rocks and we're beginning to
do that
all right so the last question if you'll
indulge me seth is a follow-up to that
so
obvious said that there'll be many of
these discovered with via ruben space
reuben observatory and that we should
send cubesats to go do it and i said
well it'd be great you know if you knew
a billionaire
who happens to want to send you know
spacecraft to proxima centauri
just get them to send the money to go
chase after a muammar
catch up to it pretty quickly do you
think we should be spending money to
chase after these potential techno
signatures or spend more money observing
them with
upcoming astronomical observatories well
the
the latter to just keep an eye out is
not anything that costs money because
we're doing it anyhow i mean it costs
money but that money is there
if you were to go to somebody like yuri
milner indeed and
and ask for money to catch up with um
i i'm not sure that's actually
worthwhile i mean it's
very unlikely that if umua was you know
deliberately sent this way that it's the
last thing to be deliberately sent
this way you have to ask yourself we
finally had a telescope
there on uh on the island of hawaii that
could find something like
and it found it within a year or two of
opening up so
if there's only one of them that's a
tremendous
coincidence in time so i think you know
it's very hard to build a rocket to
catch up with the movement none of our
rockets could
you'd have to build a whole loom rocket
and uh you know i
i think you'd do better to spend the
money on observations
that's right well seth i know you have
to go thank you for being so generous i
point out i have another interview
with seth we recorded earlier that'll be
out tune in subscribe to seth's podcast
big picture science
and the seti institute youtube channel
is available subscribe donate to the
seti institute as i do
seth i want to thank you so much i'll
stick around answer a couple more
comments and questions from my audience
love talking to you seth as always have
a wonderful day say hi to jill tarter
and frank drake and hopefully we'll get
you back on soon thanks so much seth
thank you brian it's been a pleasure
thank you so much
all right so i'll stick around and
answer
any potential questions that i can
answer in the chat room this is so much
fun talking to seth i did do an
interview with him
beforehand we talked for almost an hour
about the book itself
confessions of an alien hunter it's
pretty funny we've been talking a lot
about aliens this week
and i do hope i will have on at least
one of the two pilots uh
who is involved in the famous tic tac
video recorded not too
far away from uh not too far away from
where i
am here in san diego off the coast of
san clemente island where there's a
naval air station
by commander fravor and
alex dietrich and others and two f-18
hornets these are renowned pilots and
they're nobody
to scoff at we did a record yesterday
with mick west and you can find that
video in the
recorded yesterday or recent uploads
live videos and i'm hoping that frank
drake on i'm going to ask
seth to indulge me and put me in touch
with frank drake because one of the
things i always talk about
is how when you talk about the drake
equation which is quite frequently
brought up
and pointed to as an example of um how
numerous how populous life should be in
the solar system in the not in the solar
system in the galaxy
and perhaps in other galaxies it's never
analyzed with respect to
the error bar associated with that
number
in other words drake's equation which uh
you know has become the kind of the
talisman
and frank just celebrated his uh his one
recent birthday recently
uh at uh at the seti institute and the
drake equation is about 60 years old i
think it's exactly 60 years old
and it's about a six-term equation it
gives the number of
civilizations at which there should be
life and perhaps technologically
sophisticated life not some sort of
amoeba
like my friend or former guest on the
show andy weir talks about in
project hail mary it's an actual
technological
uh advanced civilization that we could
communicate with or hear signals from
in the form that seth and his colleagues
use radio detection
uh to uh to attempt to detect
and the equation is given as a product
of certain terms lifetime of a
civilization number of stars
produced and so forth um
and and but it's never mentioned what
the uncertainty in each one of those
terms is
and actually we've gotten very good at
reducing the uncertainty in certain ones
a certain of those terms in other words
the kepler satellite has has calculated
and measured the number of stars in the
milky way galaxy that hosts planets in
habitable zones where liquid water
would be expected to exist it's quite
normal to
understand that we now know that better
than frank drake could have ever
imagined back in 1961
however other terms they're complete
ignorance but how do you know what the
lifetime average lifetime
of a civilization is so i think it's
it's quite uh
it's quite interesting that these
equations i would never accept
from one of my beloved undergraduates
here at uc san diego and i point that
out
and it's not to be ridiculed edwin
hubble produced his famous hubble
diagram
which expresses the redshift distance
relationship between
distance distant galaxies he expressed
it
as an xy plot where on the x-axis was
was distance on the y-axis was
recessional velocity and there were no
error bars on that plot either
and yet it was absolutely correct in
other words distant galaxies
are moving away at a greater speed the
farther away they are
from the milky way galaxy and it was
done
with uh exactly no treatment of
so-called propagation of errors
and it was actually overestimated by a
factor of seven
which led as i described in my book my
book
um to an over estimate of this expansion
rate led to an underestimate of the age
of the universe
because things are so far apart that
they didn't need as much time to get as
far away from the milky way as we
observed
them uh imputed them to be therefore the
milky way was thought to be seven times
younger than it actually is not known to
be now
or about two billion years old which
meant that it was younger than the earth
was known to be
back in 1929 so even something that is
known
to be wrong can have validity it can
point
observers and theorists and and
experimentalists
in a direction which later is proven to
be right i give an example of this
recently on some interview i did um and
that was maxwell
james clark maxwell's one of the
greatest uh theoretical physicists in
human history
and he came up with maxwell's equations
which describe electromagnetism
and these equations are four equations
that describe the interplay between
electric fields and charges magnetic
fields and currents
and then the interplay between a
changing electric field and the magnetic
field generated from that changing
electric field
and vice versa and so it propagates
through uh in substitution
you can actually generate and predict
the existence of what are called
electromagnetic waves or electromagnetic
radiation
and this was a complete bolt from the
blue he never expected this to be the
case
and of course it made him wonder well
hmm i don't ever
recall a wave that existed without some
medium in which it is waving
how can you have a wave like a sound
wave it vibrates air molecules their
density and pressure change in the
medium and the air in which the sound
waves are propagating
an ocean wave you have an ocean wave
which is water supports the wave
oscillating ocean wave that supports the
energy propagation
that we call longitudinal or ocean waves
uh those are also
was waves supporting a medium so what
supports
the wave that he discovered in his
equations which are absolutely correct
the electromagnetic wave of course we
know it is you can type it in the
comment section what is the
medium that supports the electromagnetic
oscillation phenomena
we'll put it there anyone put it there
in the comments first one there
gets a starred comment and put up on the
screen
anybody put it in the comment section
there
i'll take it with either spelling ether
spelling
come on that's a good joke folks
nobody's putting it up there you guys
are all talking about aliens
all right fine nobody's going to say it
ether he basically thought of the ether
although he didn't call it that
he came up with a mechanistic support
mechanism that would
sorry for the redundancy that would
support the
uh the vibrations that would transmit
mechanically transmit
the oscillating phenomena basically
vortices gears
etc little tiny gears was the mechanism
totally laughable and you can imagine it
you can imagine
if twitter or youtube or something
existed back
in the early middle 1800s uh he would
have been mocked he would have been shut
down he would have been canceled
and that would have led to the premature
suffocation of
an ultimately proven correct theory and
so too maybe with the drake equation
jim yes mcmanus thank you um uh
and ender enters thank you kuplex yup
you guys all got it
kieran you guys are arguing too much in
the chat room to get it but it was ether
or aether
exactly and actually the ether
experiment was done at my alma mater
case western shout out to cleveland ohio
anyone in the chat room from cleveland
put a thumbs up because i love cleveland
ohio
and it was done by michaelson and
morally michaelson was of course one of
the first americans i think might have
been the first to win a nobel prize in
physics
and that was a null result experiment
it's a fascinating subject
not only could the mechanism uh that
maxwell proposed to support the
perplexing phenomena of electromagnetic
radiation
not be proven in other words there is no
such thing as an ether there is no such
thing as a
as a gear or vertical mechanism
supporting the mechanical
oscillation of waves as as maxwell
thought there was and that was required
but michelson morally could not detect
the earth's motion
with respect to the ether wind so at the
time it was considered
the the most important failed experiment
in human history
in other words the failure to detect the
ether wind was thought to be a failure
of michelson and morley not a correct
experiment which we now know
so sometimes a null result is actually
more important than getting a positive
result
and einstein actually considered that
one of the most important results that
led to him ultimately
coming up with the theory special theory
of relativity
so all this is to say that some of these
uh predictions and conjectures are
things like the drake equation
and that are ultimately maybe their
guides maybe they're loose conjectures
uh we shouldn't spend so much effort
maybe uh focusing so much on them i mean
so much attention has gone into the
drake equation
there are books written adam frank is
coming on the podcast
he's actually going to give like a
webinar if you guys are interested in
that
it'll be like a physics colloquium i
thought you guys are
or would get a kick out of like what do
we do as actual physicists i mean you
guys can't come into my lab
where it would be really cool to have
kind of like a lab day someday
maybe we'll do that someday but for now
or come to one of my telescopes in chile
or somewhere like that but
uh but at some point um i would like to
have like you guys come to my classes
or hear like a guest lecture and adam
frank is one of the world's greatest
lecturers and he's written great books
and so i really want you guys to attend
it so i'm going to set up like a webinar
and adam is going to give a webinar a
class
and he's going to give it based on this
great book that he wrote called
light of the stars in which he
conjectures that we should use
basically greenhouse gas emission as
a form of seti as a form of searching
for extraterrestrial
not intelligence but intelligence needed
to construct
farming one of the first forms of
technology humans invented was
agriculture
that led to a modification and and geo
um
and geoengineering and reforming of our
planet you know they say that
that agriculture and livestock and and
cultivation is responsible for a great
deal of of
a greenhouse and man-made although a lot
of it's bovine made
global warming emissions and so forth
and so
why not look for those as a possible
signature of technology
again it's not like making an iphone or
youtube channel
but nevertheless it is a form of
modification
so we're going to have that discussion
in the next a week or two look for that
from professor adam frank university of
rochester
i was thinking of doing it as i say like
a class like a webinar like a colloquium
or we could have it as a you know just a
standard
live stream but you know sometimes i get
fewer
uh subscriptions or people actually
unsubscribe for some reason
from the live stream which is not that
great and i want to give just an update
on where the channel is going
i'm going to have some very deep dives
into uh single topics look
next week for a very deep dive from dr
delilah gates she is i believe the
second african-american woman
to get a phd in uh theoretical physics
from harvard university
and she's a world expert in black holes
and so she
uh has given the me the indulgence of
of doing two episodes of the into the
impossible podcast one is a deep dive
into her thesis research on the spin
properties of
maximal dynamical black hole properties
and that'll be of interest
to nerds like me and many of you and
then one is kind of a black hole primer
or primer
black holes 101 everything you wanted to
know about black holes
she's brilliant she happens to be the
daughter of jim gates uh who is
professor at brown university my alma
mater for my phd
and uh he was he's been a guest twice on
the podcast
and uh he is the president of american
physical society uh
and so it's really uh delightful i've
had andrewian
and her daughter sasha sagan and i've
now had on a father and daughter
now i have to get on a mother and son i
don't know i'm gonna get into all the
genealogies but
whatever we're gonna get on all the
different possible permutations that we
can do
but anyway delilah's going to go deep
into the physics of black holes
and you're going to really like that
everything you want to know about cosmic
censorship naked singularities
black hole information paradox we're
going to have some awesome graphics
custom made
i'm going to be doing stuff on loop
quantum gravity a deep dive there
face off quantum gravity face off
and then we're going to do a couple of
deep dives into
chirality lorenzen and and finally we're
going to go back and do a couple more
interviews
with uh craig calendar is a professor of
philosophy here at uc san diego
uh anthony aguirre who is a professor at
uc santa cruz
go banana slugs and he talks about a
wonderful book called
cosmological coins ways to understand
the cosmos
via our nature of space and time so let
me go back
up and answer some of your questions yay
for black halls of course
live streams you guys love them please
share the channel with your friends
as i said sometimes people unsubscribe
and it's not just because they don't
like
uh they don't like you know mick west or
whatever as i said i'm trying to get
either commander fravor and or commander
dietrich on next week i'd love to talk
to commander dietrich because
i've got daughters and they want to be
pilots and she's an amazing amazing role
model for them
and and she was part of this event as
well and
fraver gets a lot more attention and i'd
love for her to get some attention too
for
some of the projects she's working on as
well
so uh let me look through here what kind
of things you guys are interested in
another guest i'm thinking of having
back on uh roger penrose yes his
birthday's coming up he's turning 90.
i'm gonna have him back on thank you tim
for that suggestion
i'm speaking at his 90th birthday party
that's going to be really exciting yeah
jim gates his daughter
is she i i am very happy that she's
coming on my podcast for her first
podcast she's actually going to be on
nova i believe
um so i'm going to be able to say you
guys are going to be able to say you saw
her first
into the impossible brian keating she is
such an amazing
uh brilliant human being and she's just
such a delight i just love
uh talking to her let me see if i have
the thumbnail i can find from her
somewhere here but uh but share the
channel with people you know it's it's
an educational channel
but it's also entertainment i'm trying
to to bring that up yes lady blah blah
thank you so much hit the like button
leave comments i guess it helps the
algorithm to get stuff on the whole
sagan family yeah sasha has a brother
love to get him on um nom chomsky i'm
thinking of having him back on
maybe with uh some of these alien uh
folks because he's spoken a lot about
aliens communication he actually is an
anti-alien he doesn't think aliens exist
um he thinks that probability is almost
zero my friend kurt jamal has had him on
many many times but as i said i really
um
want to have this be the
free university yeah joe rogan i don't
think so
um i'd love to i'd love to have him on
um
i don't know necessarily if he would
even
uh be aware of the of the channel but i
think of this as you know
as the only free university that you can
attend in your pajamas
where i get the best you know guest
professors in the world
sometimes i'll do deep dives i'll bring
in some cool graphics
i have an awesome studio here that's
coming back online
you're going to see some cool green
screen technology
i'm going to mostly do in the science
realm but i'll throw in some
current event stuff here and there and
some science fiction um
but you know the more you guys show show
interest in things
i will i will bring in um the guests
that you guys like
so let me know if you want nom chomsky
if you want to hear from certain
speakers i'm having jeremy england who's
a professor
um in georgia he wrote a book called
life is fire
which is coming kind of like intelligent
design but from a jewish perspective
the counter uh kind of in contrast to uh
the
stephen meyer podcast which is really
interesting and i appeared recently in a
podcast called unbelievable which is a
really big channel
uh with um with stephen meyer and i in
debate
and um yeah joe rogan you know he's
interesting you know i felt like you
know a year ago i looked back at my
statistics and i had 2 000 subscribers
and now i have 28 000 and i just i i
really treasure every one of you guys
and people say oh like how many
subscribers do you want i'll tell you
right now
i want a hundred thousand subscribers
and the reason why is very simple it's
not for like ego or whatever when i talk
to a publisher
they say how many subscribers do you
have they don't they don't ask like
how bright are your subscribers who are
your previous guests i've had nine nobel
prize winners on
uh i don't know a single podcast even
the nobel you know committee
they have fewer subscribers than i do
but they ask you know how many
subscribers do you have it doesn't even
matter what your guests are
because they want to sell so many books
and they know that about one percent
of a podcast audience will buy books
that's just the rule of publishing in
their business i don't blame them
their business they have to run it like
a business uh and if i were running that
business cutthroat business
there's only so much attention one
percent of the audience will buy books
is the rule of thumb that they use
therefore if if you guys buy books or
i'm not even
imploring you guys to buy books uh but
nevertheless that's the rule of thumb so
that if i have a hundred thousand subs
a thousand of you guys a thousand subs
will buy books that means
that if their authors go on 10 of such
podcasts
a million people will see it that means
10 000 people will buy the books
that will definitely get a non-fiction
author onto the new york times
bestseller list which is all they really
care about
because for the rest of their life they
can put down new york times best seller
list now my book was not a new york
times bestseller
um i actually had more sales than that
uh but for whatever reason
uh it didn't you know it was spread out
over too long a period of time to count
towards the best seller list
let me totally honest that's just the
way that things worked
and it really doesn't matter i wrote a
book against the nobel prize it's not
like i'm looking for some accolades
uh that's not what matters what i care
about again
my mission is i'm a public employee i
work for the state of california i've
been supported by nasa
the national science foundation or the
department of energy
my whole life i was a public school kid
my whole life
i never attended a private school until
i went to college and i went to college
on a scholarship
so i never had advantages i was always a
byproduct of public school education
uh i owe you out there you guys i may
never meet you i mean 28
000 people now it's grown 26 000 it's
grown 10x
almost you know more than 10x uh in a
year
and and i just really treasure everybody
out there but
the reason i wanted to grow is so that i
can get the people that you guys really
want to see
to pay you back for the the gifts that
you guys have given me and people like
me i believe it's my moral obligation as
a publicly funded scientist
to communicate to you in terms you can
understand to get guests like seth
like um you know like the nobel prize
winning scientist that i've had on
and uh and and the guests that you're
interested in seeing you know i'm
interested in getting
people um from all walks of life and and
and um and i love the suggestions that
you guys are giving me
so please keep that up uh that's my
mission that's all i care about
you'll never hear me saying oh i want a
million subs i want to you know people
talk about getting subs for specific
reasons
i'm telling you my metric i'm a
scientist i think scientifically
quantitatively
that's the only reason that's what
publishers care about and i won't talk
about it
any you know more than i need to uh but
please do yeah share it with your family
with your friends
we get to that number and then i'll stop
talking about it
and uh the other thing that seems to
make a dent at youtube and i've spoken
at google and
and so forth and my friends there do
tell me yeah commenting on every bit
even if you just say commenting
you know hi or whatever in the actual
comment section these live chats are
great
but if you actually just put something
high in the actual comment section
that tends to tell youtube that that
folks are really interested
and if you hit the notification bell it
will send you an email
as soon as i go live or whatever or when
i premiere a video like this one with
delilah gates please don't miss that one
because i really want her career to just
explode she's going from harvard to
princeton
as i said second african-american in
history woman to to do what she's doing
um and you can say you heard her here
first she
is a brilliant uh she's a beautiful
individual in
all possible ways i i cannot wait for
you guys to see
what she has in store for you uh i hope
that will be on tuesday for now i have
to go
on to a telescopic teleconic
meeting and i just enjoyed this so much
talking with you guys
and uh the universe expands into
nothingness
yeah i'll put some of these up there hit
the like button yeah sure thank you guys
so much
i really love it blah blah thank you
guys so much kieran
uh gregory chain i don't know who that
is but i'll look into it
um yeah absolutely guys thank you so
much and for now yeah frank wilcheck i'm
hoping to have him back that's great
shawn carroll
yeah i had all these guys on you know
another thing that that is a little bit
uh
interesting is i had noam chomsky jim
simons um
uh one mile to say hell these guys on
and women on
like jill tarter you know i had like
four thousand two thousand subscribers
and now with the help from you guys now
i'm up to close to 30 you know 28k
um now you know we could really leverage
it and uh and get even more
and i want to get some great some some
great new new people that come out with
new books brian green
hope to have him on some day um and and
with your help we'll get there so thank
you all so much for being such great
help
and ambassadors and partners on this
journey i'm doing it
uh to uh to stoke imagination to slake
your curiosity and to pay you guys back
for all you do
for my universe so i'll take you out
with a new
uh video produced by my uh my my intern
sloan sobi
stewart volkow my super producer lucas
shineback here
at uc san diego and wherever they are in
the multiverse
in the universe and i'm gonna say
goodbye till next week guys
enjoy the weekend